and so we would take the freight
elevator down to the bottom and we would
light a joint and we'd once you had the
freight elevator no one could come in on
you right so we take it down to the
basement without a joint and he told me
his stories like one time he came in
with a black guy and he goes i got
[ __ ] out of my loft last night and i
was like for real and he was like dude
it was crazy you know how good sex got
to be to get back into a loft and get
[ __ ] out again i was like and so we
would sit that and then
i realized i was going using that for
the there and i was i was like what if i
could come down here and work out like
you know take a little break from work
go down to the basement do push-ups do
sit-ups with a gay guy no no just by
myself because once you took it down no
one could come in on you no one could
find you no one can see what you're
doing right so i'd go down and this is a
little sidebar the aster place barnes
noble had no air conditioning right none
right so if i would have to take off all
my clothes i would want to get them to
sweaty right work out right
dry off
and then put my clothes back on towels
paper towels paper towels and or just
sit there for a little bit and relax
put all my clothes back on go back up
and just go back to work have a coffee
eat diet fuel was big then i feel like
like six of those right be like humming
like a junkie right um and then one day
my my boss
uh brought me down to the uh basement or
to his office
i remember and he was like um
he was like i mean you spend a lot of
time in the freight over or in the
basement aren't you i said well the
travel books are down there he's like
you know we have
cameras everywhere right i was like i
didn't know that and he was like oh
you're fired i was like i quit and he
went
great
and i walked out and then i walked out
and i walked out and
a week later uh will smith discovered me
will smith discover me and i got a
development deal
and where did will smith see you uh his
people david talked about the guy who
worked for him uh discovered me at the
boston comedy club i did an article
[Music]
and so then i got to deal with will
smith i moved out here for seven months
lived at the universal sheridan
developing a sitcom and then i came back
to new york and i had money and i had
like i think i got a tv show and i went
back to new york and i went back to the
astor place figuring
everyone knew i got fired for working
out in the basement in my underwear
and i walked back up to the information
desk and the gay guy was there and he
was like um
he was like what's up
i was like nothing and he just we went
back to our i said he said uh our
manager got fired and i was like shut
the [ __ ] up and he's like guess what he
guess what he does for a living he
doesn't work at barnes noble
and he goes i'm still gay he goes guess
what happened last night and he we we
didn't talk about me getting fired or
anything we talked about one of his
sexual explains i didn't even tell him
that i had gotten a deal i didn't still
work there i don't know i really liked
that guy i was i was a cool guy it's
cool you meet people who then affect the
way you see the rest of the things
[Music]
you